what I'm tired of hearing is that you
know it's all a mini money minting
machine and it just exists great money
and it's a soul this kind of place but
what people are realize is that we're
there to help companies with aerosol
problems I'm tired of hearing that Wall
Street is actually the cause of most of
our country's problems Wall Street
actually plays a very important part of
our development and our security the
industry can get some negative press
what I found since I've started is that
everyone I work with is great you know
genuinely kind people i think marx and
engels would agree that capitalism has
passed
done wonders however is indeed hard to
talk about capitalism without talking
this is a place where dreams come true
and makes you feel that anything is
possible and you can do really well in
life